hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my forms readers yinka who's
asking to both Twitter so he wrote in
saying none of us have asked you how
you've gotten all the Puerto follows
that you have how did you do it can you
teach us to show us how you did it so
thanks for the question you care I'm a
big fan of using Twitter I at the start
didn't really understand Twitter I
thought you know people are posting
about their cats what day for lunch and
why would I want to be a part of this
and then I just did a quick search for
my name and found that people were
talking about me and I wasn't part of
the conversation so I started off just
watching and anytime somebody mentioned
me or my website I just give them you
know thank you just trying to empower my
champions and get them to one of you
know write more content and share more
about my website so that was kind of
phase one and I encourage entrepreneurs
just to start that as phase one monitor
your name monitor your company name and
just recognize when people promote you
or talk about you luckily for me
everything was good I didn't get any
negative complaints but you know all the
positive ones I tried to recognize and
just go make them feel like they were
important and to thank them they were
fans and so you want to empower those
guys to go out and talk more about your
business that's how I got started to
have the success and have a lot more
people following you and have some
traction what I found as couple keys
that hopefully you can use to implement
it to your business the first is really
the fine your market so know who you're
trying to attract on Twitter and it may
not be having a million followers that
may not be your goal I mean we're
closing in a hundred thousand right now
for my account and I know my audience is
entrepreneurs and so that's a big
audience I can attract a lot of people
that's what I'm really passionate but I
love helping entrepreneurs love
answering questions I love sharing new
information that I find that's helping
me that hopefully can help you guys as
well for your audience it may not be a
large audience and that's okay but you
want to have a specific audience in mind
when you're creating content for your
your tweets so that's first the second
thing is create awesome content so it's
not just promotional stuff if you follow
I twitter stream you're not just seen
me saying hey you know half off sale or
come by my book or whatever it's talking
more about value add information for
entrepreneurs so now i'm sharing quotes
i define inspirational i'm sharing
articles that i found helpful and useful
sharing stuff from my own website and
you know it's all value ID stuff so it's
not sales pitches that people are going
to tune that out and i think if
somebody's just blasting you with sales
information you're probably gonna tune
it out too but someone's adding value to
your life on a regular consistent basis
then you're going to want to you know
consume that more and more and the more
people you know like seen your
information the more they're going to
want to be curious about your website
curious about your products and services
want to sign up for your newsletter all
the fun stuff that comes along with it
so you know you can't have a few
promotions in there but keep the most of
it being all value I stuff again
targeted towards your audience the next
thing you can do is optimize your tweet
so what I found is you know you can send
the same tweet out at different times
during the day and have a much greater
response on one time versus the other so
i used some tools to help me find what
time of day do most of my people read my
tweets and from there i'm able to
optimize the schedules that I go out so
use this tool called crowd booster which
is free which will analyze your Twitter
records and it'll show you what times a
day to send your tweets out and give you
recommendations and then I use a tool
called buffer app which is also free
which then allows you to schedule your
tweets out at certain times so I get a
lot of money in the morning so I'll send
them out at seven eight nine a.m. and
then a couple in the afternoon as well
and that's what I found to be the best
time to me so you may be completely
different so just depends on your
audience and I use those tools to help
me get my message out so that I'm
hitting people at ideal times so
definitely a great way to go about it
because you're spending that time
creating your tweets anyway it might as
well try to hit the maximum number of
people who are following you and then
the last part is you got to promote it
so you know for my Twitter account a lot
of people will find me from searches but
most of the people will find me from the
promotions that I do so it's on my
website it's in my email it's in my
newsletter so all of your communications
you want to have your twitter address
on there to encourage people to want to
sign up and follow you it's on my
business card I don't have a phone
number of my business card but i have my
twitter account on my business card so
all of the marketing and communications
i do includes my twitter account and the
more work you do to you know marketing
from your business the more you're going
to see it come out in twitter followers
and people following you online as well
so all the offline stuff you're doing to
should include your twitter to get
people to follow you online so that's
what I've done and it's helped then it's
it's grown every month and it's exciting
and I love you know being engaged to
people I try to answer all the tweets
that come back to me so it's another one
that you can take take back with you
people feel they can have a personal
connection with you they're more likely
to want to follow you and stay engaged
so when people ask me questions I might
do a YouTube video like this or might
you know toot them back with reply and
recognize the people who are supporting
you and they'll keep supporting you and
tell their friends about it so it's a
it's definitely a process but it's
helped and it's been a lot of fun so
well that helps you guys if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
makes me want to do more of these videos
for you and if you have a question about
Twitter or if you want to share what
you're doing on Twitter that's been
really effective I love to hear what you
have to say if you wanted to comment
underneath this video and we'll see you
on the next episode
you